ermahgerd experience of
behind-the-scenes hey guys I'm making a
Daily Grace look this is how it happens
look at that there's my lighting there's
my camera I'm trying to make I'm making
Thursday's Daily Grace right now
actually
all right advance who does that I never
ever do that but I'm trying to do it
today because I got so much [ __ ] going
on tomorrow that I won't be able to do
it
and I'm cooking something whoa but I'm
not gonna tell you what you're after
wait it's hot in the kitchen guys
how are you just checking in give me a
little sneak peek the thing that I'm
making is in the oven right now so this
is the waiting time when you're like you
stick in to be good this must be how a
dad feels when they wait for their wife
she give birth and they're like is it
gonna be attractive baby if it's not who
knows
I've never been a father before maybe at
some point my life I will be um yeah so
just wanna live this little joke for you
I have to go edit Wednesday's Daily
Grace does this look attractive and cool
do you feel like I'm we're watching MTV
right now whoa and then I'm gonna go and
do my time trial act today
yeah it's raining in New York which
means everyone hates everything and
everyone's pissed off about everything
okay I'm gonna go um I've said I'm gonna
go a lot probably never won't call me
I'll just stay no I'm definitely
definitely gonna go I'm sweating in all
the crevices that's a fun way to find
out where your crevices ours when you
sweat bye